[Música]
y
cuando sólo quedan dos meses para que se
celebren las elecciones presidenciales
nueva yor se encuentra como el resto del
país tremendamente polarizado por esta
pandemia en la que nos encontramos
inmersos y por una ola de protestas
contra el racismo que asola eeuu desde
el pasado mes de mayo aquí ya se puede
solicitar la boleta de voto ausente y
está previsto que al menos 5 millones de
neoyorquinos lo hagan y no vayan a votar
en persona algo que ha provocado las
reacciones por parte de los funcionarios
electorales que asegura que no tienen ni
la mano de obra suficiente ni los
recursos para contabilizar estas boletas
en el tiempo preciso así que dicen que
los resultados oficiales podrían tardar
en conocerse días e incluso semanas
además también se ha habilitado una gran
sede electoral y esto es el enorme
espacio madison square garden donde
podrán votar todos aquellos que lo
deseen hacer de manera anticipada estará
abierto desde el 24 de octubre al 1 de
noviembre para todos los que quieran
ejercer su voto días antes
[Música]
cuando faltan dos meses para las
elecciones presidenciales los candidatos
miran a florida y al voto latino que
puede ser decisivo en estos comicios
pero es un voto el de los hispanos que
está muy dividido porque por un lado
están los puertorriqueños que en los
últimos tiempos han llegado a este
estado por la situación a raíz del
huracán maría y han puesto en entredicho
la gestión que tuvo donald trump en esa
situación de catástrofe natural y luego
estarían en los votos desde los
cubanoamericanos y los venezolanos que
se aprobarían en la política que ha
estado llevando el actual gobierno de
eeuu tanto en la isla de cuba común con
las sanciones al gobierno de nicolás a
maduro sin embargo joe biden y los
demócratas dicen que el gobierno de
donald trump no ha dado el estatus de
protección temporal a los venezolanos
para que puedan estar aquí legalmente
algo que él sí que va a impulsar si
llega a ser presidente
[Música]
la carrera por la elección presidencial
del próximo 3 de noviembre aquí en
california está al rojo vivo en un
estado eminentemente demócrata es seguro
que va a ganar yo byd en el gran número
de votos electorales que da este estado
pero lo que está en juego y lo que está
sobre la mesa es la forma en que se va a
realizar esta votación primero porque
aquí se va a hacer el voto vía correo y
hay muchas zonas rurales de california
donde el sistema de correos pues no
tiene la prontitud que tienen las
grandes ciudades y esto ya ha causado
una gran política la otra gran
preocupación de los californianos es el
sistema electrónico de votos que ya se
probó en la última elección que tuvimos
aquí en california en las elecciones
partidarias de demócratas y republicanos
y no tuvo buenos resultados demora en
los conteos y además fallas en las mesas
electrónicas de votación creo que ahí va
a estar el gran secreto de esta elección
que repito ya está al rojo vivo
[Música]